miles de niños cariocas regresan a las
aulas por primera vez en 8 meses el
martes las escuelas de río de janeiro
reabrieron parcialmente sus puertas un
total de 61 mil alumnos retornaron a las
aulas sin embargo son sólo los alumnos
de último año de primaria y secundaria
quienes regresan y lo hacen bajo un
modelo híbrido cada grupo cada grupo
tendrá dos días de clases presenciales
durante tres horas cada día y durante
toda la semana los días que no estén en
actividad presencial seguirán estudiando
online y esas clases serán guiadas por
nuestros maestros brasil suspendió las
clases presenciales en marzo tras un
aumento de los contagios sin embargo la
necesidad de retornar a clases se hace
cada vez más evidente por las falencias
en la educación a distancia
están teniendo dificultades porque
simplemente pasaban mucho tiempo fuera
de las aulas y todo es nuevo esto para
los profes tanto para nosotros los
profesores como para los alumnos no
tenía la costumbre de estudiar en casa
sin la guía de un profesor
a pesar de todo el buen trabajo online
de los profesores un trabajo con mucha
dedicación tanto de profesores como
alumnos nada reemplaza el aula nada
reemplaza el hecho de estar juntos
[Música]
no obstante médicos y sindicatos de
maestros se oponen a la reapertura por
considerar que no existen las garantías
para la salud de los alumnos con más de
6 millones de casos y 170 mil fallecidos
el gigante latinoamericano es el tercer
país con mayor índice de contagios y de
muertes en el mundo